foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Brian Greene
and this Faith Shaylee everyone thank
you very much
this is Brian Green's book
um in large print because time has
ravaged my eyesight
um and I first interviewed you Brian a
few months after this book came out in
May of 2020 which everyone can imagine
was a very specific time you were
Upstate I think I was in an apartment on
the upper west side it was on Zoom the
notion of time during those early days
when people said lockdown it was it was
a very it was a very specific
experience to talk about time then now
to return to this it's the same book it
was interesting to see what I dog-eared
to see what what moved me in fact to
tears again I took a whole bunch of new
notes and I love that we're having this
discussion at the New York Historical
Society because I mean not only is this
book about the entire history of the
universe and about when his history will
cease to exist but also because history
is arguably both a science and an art
and you you characteristically make room
in this book especially for mathematics
and music for Schrodinger and
Shakespeare and I mean it's it's just a
joy to turn to the index of this book
because you'll find there's Higgs
particle there's Mick Jagger there's
there's big bang big bounce big crunch
big rip
um there's over the rainbow Poe Sylvia
Plath and you spend a moment on
cheesecake which I think which I think
vegan vegan cheese vegan cheesecake and
you make it germane so my goal is to get
to The Cheesecake tonight
um so history is about stories and in
this book your story kind of begins with
what you call the romance of mathematics
what do you mean by that or what did you
mean by that uh well it's interesting I
grew up you know four blocks from here
you know 81st Street and at an early age
my dad who was a composer singer
musician he didn't go to college he had
what he called an spht Seward Park High
School Dropout so good and uh and so but
he he loved ideas and so he taught me
the basics of arithmetic at a very young
age and then it sent me these problems
like multiply this 30 digit number by
this 30 digit number and I would spend
the weekends four blocks from here with
large pieces of construction paper just
multiplying these numbers out and it
just felt to me so compelling to do
something that nobody had done before
now in those cases it's because it
wasn't interesting yeah you weren't
trying to just get your dad's
approbation you loved it yeah totally no
I just got pulled into this world of
numbers and it was kind of a romance of
this mathematical language which I feel
strongly is one that we invent that we
don't discover but this wondrous thing
that we compose that allows us to go off
into strange places of prime numbers and
the Riemann zeta function we all make
these ideas up but this world that we
create is so rich and compelling raise
your hand if you're waiting for him to
say Riemann zeta function
um but in the book you say that part of
the romance and this is this is relevant
to this notion of thinking about our
time is and and how finite it is is that
mathematics is a journey toward insights
so fundamental they will never change
mathematics is permanent
the the truths are and to me that is a
remarkable quality it was really first
emphasized to me again when I was quite
young I I you know I went to is44 which
is like three blocks from here uh and I
exhausted the math curriculum relatively
quickly so one of the teachers there
gave me a a letter I didn't know what it
said at the time he said take this go up
to Colombia and find somebody to teach
you so so together with my my older
sister I was like a little tiny you know
just like this so we'd like walk and we
started knocking on doors randomly
handing this letter and most would read
it and hand it back but in the math
department knocked on one door and gave
it to a fellow and he read and he said
sure I'll teach you uh for free we
didn't have any money or anything and
and so uh I would go three times a week
and he would take me on these
mathematical Journeys and and he was the
one who really when I started to get
interested in physics and and I was
asking him like why do you do math why
is it your thing and he said I I I do
math because once you prove a theorem it
stands forever
and it finally hit me everything else is
impermanent but these deep truths that
come from this language of mathematics
they do stand beyond the test of time
and so there is something deeply
compelling to latch on to those
qualities of the world that are
immutable
and Mathematics certainly are among
those qualities
and your grasp of mathematics and and
your participation in the way
mathematics has pushed our understanding
has led people like you to understand
that the math tells us the universe is
going to end right yeah I mean it is
interesting you develop a language
initially to describe everyday objects
and entities with Precision that's
really where mathematics comes from but
then you can follow the math to begin to
talk about things that we can't directly
see or observe or test and yet are
relevant to our sense of who we are and
how we fit into some Grand picture and
certainly after Albert Einstein gave us
the mathematics of the general theory of
relativity which is our understanding of
gravity that's most relevant for How the
Universe evolves on the largest of
scales when you follow that mathematics
forward in time in essence allowing you
to kind of turn a cosmic film toward the
future the frames and that Cosmic film
are not particularly happy if you go
sufficiently far into the future that's
a spoiler alert but you you don't pull
punches you kind of tell us that right
of way yeah right away and that's I kind
of want to get the bad news part over
with early in the evening
um what I mean let's get to some numbers
how how old is the Universe and how much
time do we have left yeah
my birthday's on Friday so I'm feeling
urgency yeah so so at least on human
scales it's a it's a relatively calming
story so back to the Big Bangs about
13.8 billion years and you know that's
an enormous time scale it's so large
that it even that's hard to wrap your
mind around what that really means but
just to give a sense if you were to
compress all of cosmic history from the
beginning until today into a single
calendar year as Carl Sagan told us to
do decades ago then all of recorded
history takes place in the last 10
seconds
of that calendar year
so December 31st at 11 59 and 50 seconds
is when we start to begin to record
things that are happening in the human
landscape
all the rest is the lead up to that
particular moment so that's from the
beginning until today which is enormous
but then if you go from today into the
future the time scales get even longer
and I could take us through those real
quickly if that would be a relevant
thing to do but I don't want to step on
your narrative whoever no no that's fine
I'm I'm quite breathlessly concerned
about when how long humans are going to
last yeah well that is a much more
difficult question to address it's
obviously an important one to all of us
but because humans
are these complex combination of
ingredients I believe we're still fully
governed by laws of physics so we can
pursue that further but to make
predictions about human behavior is
more challenging than describing the
behavior of the cosmos as a whole right
because this is a very self-centered
human question right because we could
kill ourselves off a planet anytime soon
and the universe isn't going to Blink
yeah and it likely will happen but uh
but but but if you put that to the side
the fact that we there's a significant
chance that we will self-annihilate one
way or another putting that to the side
you can say how long will the earth be
here at least in principle and so that's
probably on the order of 5 billion or so
more years because in about five billion
years the Sun is going to swelt over 200
times its current size it will certainly
engulf Mercury and Venus it may engulf
the Earth if it doesn't will certainly
Scorch Earth in a dramatic way if the
Earth should happen to survive that then
it will hang around for another 100
billion billion years when it will
spiral in to the dead son math tells us
all of this yeah that's the amazing
thing and and systems like the Sun and
the Earth although they seem complicated
perhaps if you just sort of think about
it casually they're actually relatively
simple what is the sun it's a spherical
ball of gas what is the Earth it's a
spherical ball of rock we have these
complex shapes with all these inner
processes that Define what it means to
be human but inside the Sun there's not
all that much going on inside the earth
not all that much going on from the
standpoint of physics that allows us to
calculate the behavior of these
macroscopic objects with significant
confidence
is is is
there a thing that is time if there is
no consciousness to Clock IT pun
intended yeah I don't know uh could time
itself simply be a product of human
Ingenuity allowing us to organize bless
you organize our perceptions of the
world around us it could be that that's
what time is but if you think somewhat
more fundamentally of time as the
language that allows us to discuss
change right that's what time really is
it allows us to say things were like
this then and they're like this now and
so there was a development and time is
the dimension along which that
development can take place now certainly
change happened before human beings who
are here right I mean we have great
confidence again you know the Big Bang
yields ultimately galaxies and stars and
planets we understand and rough outline
those processes things really did happen
and so it's suggest strongly that there
was a conception of time before we
humans were here to recognize it and
presumably there will be a conception of
time after we are gone because things
will unfold and we we call that entropy
and we will we will get to that in a
moment I just
um I love all the the little nuggets
that one picks up reading this I mean
it's hard to have a a dinner party
discussion of entropy to the extent you
can but I do love learning that the the
Big Bang the idea of the Big Bang wasn't
it articulated by a Jesuit priest yeah
it's true I don't know how many people
are familiar with the name George
lemaitre I mean just a clap if do you
know that name
pretty tepid uh everybody they might be
friends a sense yeah yeah there we go
thank you Father George yeah so so you
know not not zero but you know it is a
no name and he was an unusual character
because not only did he have a PhD in
physics from MIT from MIT but but if he
was a Jesuit priest and he deeply wanted
to understand the big questions and
after Einstein wrote down the equations
of the general theory of relativity
lemaitre was the first to successfully
apply them to the universe as a whole
Einstein had done a version of this
earlier on but the major is the one who
really pushed this idea forward and he
came to the conclusion that the Universe
should be expanding and if it's
expanding then if you sort of wind that
film in Reverse everything gets smaller
and smaller toward the path suggesting
that everything was compressed together
into what he called the Primeval Atom
sort of an initial Atom from which
everything emerged going forward in time
that is not in the Old Testament well it
depends how you interpret it yeah but
it's so fascinating to me that it was it
was a priest and we I'll let you have
the glory will you will you tell
everyone what Einstein said when he saw
the Metro's calculations yeah so so
lemaitre joins Einstein at the Solvay
conference in Brussels in 1927 to to
alert you know the Great Master
regarding what he had found using the
great Master's own equations and
Einstein just turned to him and said
your calculations are correct but your
physics is abominable yeah
Edward Einstein meant by that was you
can't believe all mathematics is
relevant to the world you have to have a
an intuition regarding which math really
tells us things that we should take
seriously about reality and which math
might be good math calculations are
correct but belongs in a mathematics
textbook not as a guide to the way the
universe actually works now the reason
Einstein knew that the calculations were
correct is he'd already seen them about
five years earlier by a Russian
physicist named Alexander Friedman who
kind of did the same calculation and
showed at times and at that point
Einstein said your calculations are
incorrect and he wrote a little
criticism of the paper sent it to the
journal but Friedman stayed on Einstein
and and proved time synthetic
calculations were correct so Einstein
changes his criticism to say you know
the calculations are fine I don't think
it's relevant to the world but in the
margin
of the criticism you can literally see
that Einstein is saying but this is
irrelevant to anything that we would
care and then he like nicely didn't
include that in the criticism because a
little bit you know he rose above you
know it would sound like sour grapes at
that point but he clearly did not think
that the universe is expanding
at what point did he see the light uh
well he saw the light when we saw the
light so Edwin Hubble using the powerful
telescope at Mount Wilson Observatory
saw the light from distant galaxies that
he recognized by virtue of how the light
was being stretched that the galaxies
were all rushing away and as galaxies
Rush away the light that they send
toward us will get stretched outward
redshifted is a language that we use and
he found a pattern in the redshifts that
the father of galaxy is the faster it
was moving away which is exactly what
you'd expect from a universe that's
expanding and once that data was clear
Einstein pretty much agreed but I have
to give you a small footnote that we
never say but since it's a friendly
small group here it stays here you know
the fact of the matter is although we
tell that story it's only partly correct
certainly the data helped Einstein get
over this notion that the Universe was
static Eternal unchanging which is his
philosophical Prejudice but it was
really Arthur Eddington
another
famous physicist from that age and not
to go footnote on footnote but he's the
guy who
when a reporter said to him how does it
feel to be one of three people who
understands the general theory of
relativity he thought pensively and said
I'm trying to think with the third
person
but but but so so Eddington who clearly
Einstein respected you know he
understood the general theory of
relativity well Sheldon said that
Einstein's view that the Universe might
be static and unchanging
that the math showed that that solution
to his equations was itself unstable if
you breathe slightly in this universe if
you flick it slightly it will either
start expanding or Contracting and so
once Einstein saw that the math was
unstable he said aha this is not a
viable way of envisioning the universe
at least according to his own general
theory of relativity bottom line though
by 1931 Einstein is a convert he
realizes that space is expanding and and
while we're dealing with fun trivia you
can share with Friends The Big Bang was
coined almost just dismissively right in
on the BBC yeah yeah absolutely
um so there was an alternative theory
that was being pursued it's called the
steady state cosmology and one of the
proponents of that theory was on BBC
discussing it and sort of dismissively
refers to this other idea of an
expanding universe as it all begins in
one big bang you know and people like oh
big bang you know it'll make a great
sitcom someday yeah
um and that was in 1949. 48 yeah or 48
okay
um all right so the the two processes
that are running the show are entropy
and evolution and of course one degrades
and creates disorder and the other
creates and builds and and you talk
about how they must act as a pair you
call it the entropic two-step yeah tell
us about that yeah so so there really
are these two dominant Trends you know
if we try to understand the evolution of
the Universe from The Big Bang until
today and on to the Future you can get
mired in details and for certain
questions that's really important to do
but if it can find overall patterns and
tendencies it gives you
a better understanding of what's going
on at least from sort of a 30 000 foot
level and the two dominant processes are
number one the rise in entropy this is
called the second law of Thermodynamics
it was developed as far back as the
1800s it's something that we're all
familiar with order tends to degrade
into disorder we've been to my apartment
there you go right so you leave in the
morning and maybe it's all straightened
up you come back at night how often is
it right so so it's almost always the
case that it goes from order to disorder
and it makes sense because there are so
many ways
for things to be disordered the Legos
could be here or there or their kitchen
bathroom you know everywhere
but the very few ways for it to be
ordered so it's harder to be ordered
than disordered and when we use the
language of entropy entropy is a measure
of how much disorder that's all that it
is and the idea is that entropy tends to
increase because it's easier for things
to have higher entropy than lower
entropy and as much as that's true at
your at your house it's true in the
cosmos
so we believe the Big Bang was a highly
ordered beginning still uncertain why
that is who what or how made it ordered
at the very beginning we don't know the
answer to that but it began in that
highly ordered State and has been going
toward ever greater disorder
but then you can ask yourself well if
it's going toward ever greater disorder
what about us right these objects we're
so amazing ordered right and and that's
where this other process of evolution
comes into the story which has an
interplay with this Evolution has this
wonderful capacity to build structures
that are ever better adapted to their
environment now normally we talk about
that when you learn in high school at
the level of living systems right that's
after all how Darwin wrote it down
living systems have progeny progeny
generally can differ from their parents
those distinct characteristics that make
the child the progeny better able to
survive are likely to persist because
they will cause the being to survive and
reproduce and thereby spread to Future
Generations good but there's a version
of evolution by natural selection it's
much more General than the way Darwin
initially framed it molecules themselves
can engage in a version of evolution by
natural selection you call that chemical
combat it's a kind of chemical combat
exactly because if you have molecules in
some sense battling against other
molecules to gain raw materials because
once a molecule learns how to make a
copy of itself and this is something
that molecules can do like we know how
DNA does it's a molecule that makes a
copy of itself a molecule if it can pull
in raw materials and use its own
structure as a template for making
copies of itself those molecules that
can make more copies faster with greater
economy and stability those molecules
are going to win in the sense that
they're going to dominate the molecular
demographics
and if that molecule makes a copy that's
not precisely the same a mutation
progeny that differs from the parent if
the progeny is even better at making
copies then it will come to dominate the
environment so over a long period of
time you go from molecule to molecule to
molecule becoming ever better adapted to
the environment until you get complex
collections of molecules like us that
are pretty good at being adapted to
their surroundings and so you've got on
the one hand entropy driving us toward
ever greater disorder you've got
evolution by natural selection allowing
complex structures organized to exist
and so these two forces play off of each
other as the universe unfolds and yes
even with the
SE
I don't know if the word is anomalous
organized structures that Evolution
creates entropy still increases that's
right so you might say does evolution
violate right the second law of
Thermodynamics does the formation of an
orderly structure like a human being or
to be simpler a star or a planet does
that somehow violate the drive toward
ever greater disorder and the answer is
actually no and it's a beautiful fact
because take a star really good example
a star formed from a lot of gas that
falls in on itself because of the
gravitational pull of each molecule of
gas on every other now as the star is
forming it gives off a great amount of
heat and light in the process that heat
and light streams outward carrying away
a whole lot of disorder a whole lot of
entropy so even though the star is a is
a pocket of order if you take into
account the entirety of the environment
that the Stars formation influences
there's more disorder ejected to The
Wider world than there is order that's
formed so overall entropy goes up even
though you're left with a beautiful
ordered star again with the Lego my kids
can make a Lego castle but there are
pieces all over the carpet because they
had to root through everything to make
something with even go a little bit
further so let's say they were to use up
all those pieces on the carpet okay
where then would you get the extra
entropy thumb as it would be from when I
step on them and scream in pain sorry go
ahead that's certainly part of it you
have to take that contribution too but
as your kids are putting the Lego pieces
in they're burning up energy they are
giving off sweat and and disturbing the
molecular environment around them and if
you take into account all of that
there's more this or order being
generated than order formed you
you
know the inking you
yes that I mean sometimes we meet people
we're like I get it that's the way that
person is thinking feels like
environmental waste let's compost but um
but Consciousness you say that at some
point our capacity for Thought will be
part of what burns ourselves out yeah
yeah because if you go back just for
really smart people like you
well you know you asked a question
earlier in terms of how long could we
last yeah and as I said it's a little
hard to give a precise number because of
human behavior but you might ask a
related question which is in the best of
all worlds if we are maximally smart at
not annihilating ourselves and maximally
clever about maybe uploading our
Consciousness into more durable
structures how long could we last if
we're able to do all of that and that's
a question that we can address
because if you take into account that
the act of thinking is itself a physical
process I mean you can question that but
I'm pretty confident that that's the
case that the act of thinking is just a
physical process taking place inside of
our heads it too is subject to the
second law of Thermodynamics which means
every time you have a thought you are
emitting waste to the environment now
here's the what's the waste made of the
waste is heat
that's the most basic form of entropy
the random motion of particles created
because you've heated up the system
and if you take into account that in
roughly 10 to the 50 years from now it's
a long time right we're 10 to the 10
years from The Big Bang but stay with me
if you go 10 to the 50 years into the
future
you can calculate what the environment
will be like and you can show that the
environment will not be able to absorb
any more waste Heat at that point like
not one bit that's right one thought
could break the camel so one more
thought and the heat will not be able to
disperse outward and so you will burn up
you will fry in the process of trying to
think oh my
point when even thought itself will draw
to an end
so you already you already mentioned
um there are I feel like in in this book
you've kind of explicate just about
everything I mean Big Bang he talks
about Mick Jagger as as legendary if
he's considered through the lens of
sexual selection right he's part of our
Evolution
um but you are Swift and Unapologetic to
name at least two great Mysteries that
scientists like you have not solved one
you mentioned we we know what what the
materials of the Big Bang were we and
when I say we I mean you know when the
Big Bang happened
nobody knows how the materials got there
yeah how something was out of nothing
right right yeah and it's a who what
where where they come from yeah no it's
uh all of those are good deep questions
and I wish I had something insightful to
say about it the best that we can really
do at the moment is to know
possibilities
so one possibility might be that the Big
Bang was the beginning of our realm of
reality but that it wasn't the beginning
of everything so and since the question
of where did it come from there may have
been a whole pre-history to the Big Bang
which may have involved other Big Bangs
giving rise to other Realms but of
course that just pushes the question a
little bit further back I mean maybe far
far back but it still asks us to give an
explanation of how whatever preceded the
Big Bang
got started and and so we don't have an
answer to that the other possibility is
somewhat more conservative which is to
imagine that there is no before the Big
Bang the time itself starts with the big
bang you know a good analogy is you know
if you were to try to walk North on
planet Earth and you pass by some and
they you ask them which way is North
they point you you keep on going you
pass by somebody else they continue to
point you but when you get to the North
Pole and you say to somebody there how
do I go further north in the North Pole
they say we don't really know what that
means North begins at the North Pole you
can't go further north than the North
that's a meaningless question it may be
the same thing the time go back a
hundred a thousand a billion years go
right back to the big bang and the
notion of going further back may be as
meaningless as going further north than
the North Pole so it could have all
started
then but still I have no insight into
why there is something rather than
nothing right that's the most basic
fundamental question and by nothing I
don't mean empty space I mean truly
nothing no space no time no energy no
Quantum Fields no nothing why is it not
like that
the other ques I mean I'm sure there are
Mysteries that you articulate that I'm
not remembering but the other big one is
consciousness right so many of you know
that Brian very famous famously said to
Stephen Colbert that we are all bags of
particles and that went really well
um and um he said he said that's a great
pickup line which I thought was um yeah
and that it is a it is actually try it
um I wish I was still dating
uh uh but we don't know so these are
particles right this is particles you
and I are particles we're this we're all
made up of the same stuff and you and I
have Consciousness and this table
doesn't and we don't know why right we
don't know why
um now
there are some things that you can say
about that question clearly there's a
difference between you and the table
there are many ways of framing the
differences but for this question the
most important one is you have a certain
molecular organization that the table
does not have and that allows you to
respond to the environment in a wealth
of ways that the table can't and among
the things that you can do is you can
take in sensory information from the
external world and process it inside
your head in a way that the table cannot
now it may be that Consciousness is
nothing but the flow of particles and
the information that they carry within a
sufficiently organized coherent complex
structure in our particular case that's
a 3.3 pound gray Gloppy corrugated
crenellated object that sits in this
bone cave perched on our shoulders right
I mean so that that's that that is where
it happens for us and it may be that
Consciousness is simply the result of
complex organization and this is a
correct motion of particles so it may be
that we just come to that conclusion
now especially in a world where we're
headed toward artificial versions of
intelligence if we have sufficient
evidence I would imagine one day talking
to artificial systems that they too they
report you know chat GPT 1000 says I
really am depressed no I'm really you
know Brian I'm really sad and I'm not
you know I'm not just saying that I
really am feeling it right now you know
if if that really happens we may and
we're convinced we may come to the
conclusion that Consciousness just is
the result an emergent property that
comes from sufficiently complex
calculations
that may be the answer what you are 100
certain of is that that Consciousness
does not provide free will right there
is you say there is no free will yeah do
all scientists say there's no free will
no
but they didn't have any choice in their
in their answer but um uh you you could
have predicted that yeah um but uh but
yes I well I should qualify slightly
um under the assumption which I'm
confident of but nobody really knows
from what we just said if Consciousness
is nothing but the result of certain
physical processes then I'm convinced
that we don't have free will that free
will is a misleading notion but if
you're of the perspective that no no no
no no you got the physical but
Consciousness is something else you know
it's out there some Consciousness field
that's governed by completely different
considerations which scientists did
think right some people well what they
did was and it's a really good reference
they didn't think that about
Consciousness per se they thought about
life vitalism vitalism so the idea was
you can have whatever organization of
matter that you want but it will never
be alive until you inject something else
from the outside of Life Force you know
vitalism is exactly the right way of
talking about but nobody believes that
at least almost nobody believes that any
longer because as we have understood
life at the molecular but the
biomechanical and so forth as we've gone
deeper and deeper the need for something
beyond the physical has evaporated and
so whereas life was so mysterious a
hundred years ago that we envisioned you
needed something else for things to
become alive we no longer feel that way
and I suspect Consciousness now feels so
incredibly mysterious I mean where does
this inner world inside of our heads
come from why don't we just do what
we're doing without an inner World
taking place behind our eyeballs you can
imagine that that could be the way that
we are and yet we are not so it feels
deeply mysterious but it may be that as
we understand it better as with vitalism
the idea of something from the outside
will just go away that's my expectation
you now we didn't talk about the Free
Will part and I'm happy to uh go for it
yeah you know so once you get there I I
I have to confess I
I I would never argue with you about
anything and I wouldn't even argue with
you about free will but there is a part
of me I'll I'll listen and I'll be like
well yeah that sounds right of course
I'm sure that's all right I'm sure all
that science is right and then I will
walk out of here thinking I have free
will and by the way I will too you will
absolutely because you need to describe
the world using many levels of analysis
many kinds of stories right so write
down at the particle level the electrons
the quarks the neutrons and so forth
they We Believe are fully governed by
physical law
and so if thought is nothing but the
motion of particles like that inside of
your head then all of your thought and
all of your behavior right like right
now I just seemingly feel felt like I
made the choice to lift up the cup but
what was it you didn't I didn't at a
molecular level think look inside me as
I do this really peer inside me right
it's just the motion of particles in my
head alerting particles in my arm to
contract and move it's just the motion
of particles if you didn't know that I
was a living system you just say oh wow
a lot of particles moving all governed
by the laws of physics I mean think
about my particles it's not like they
move according to the laws of physics
for a while and then they say hang on
guys stop
wait for Brian to make a decision
okay he's made a decision keep going
the laws are governing all of the time
and so if the laws are governing all the
time then they were governing the
decision that I seemingly made so write
down at the particular level it seems
quite clear to me that the notion of our
interceding in their motion is
incoherent but go up to the human level
right the chemical the biological the
psychological the physical you come to
the human level and like you I
experience a world in which I seem to
have free will what do I view that as I
view that as it's useful probably from
an evolutionary perspective for us to
have the sensation
of free will the sensation is real we
all have it all the time I feel like I'm
in a drive receipt right now I feel like
I'm making the choices and decisions of
my next word and action and so forth the
sensations are real but the fundamental
freedom of will to which that sensation
seems to point
that is illusory
I it makes me think of kind of what you
move into in the second half of the book
about
how crucial it is in in our in the
unfolding of human existence to make up
stories to make up narratives in a way
the way you just described it is that if
we are if none of us has free will to
function as human beings then it is a
fiction it is a story We Tell ourselves
that we are in charge of our actions
yeah right and and I want to I want to
move into that part of the book
um I I'm more on the art side and and it
speaks to me right so I make I make
meaning in my life by by I I actually
survive in experience by trying to
figure out what it means by turning it
into a story that I can probably tell
somebody else and you are a gifted
writer and you help make meaning by
recognizing patterns in the universe and
the way you write them down is not only
words but numbers right yeah when you
will you talk about how language fits
into
not only our
um the way we we Face our our very short
time on this Earth as humans but in into
evolution
yeah I mean so
you know as
we have tried to survive
a vital part of that Echoes exactly what
you are describing we have a need to
Anchor our experience through some kind
of meaning presumably those of our
ancestors who had that capacity to
invest their experiences with more than
just mere survival but survival for a
reason were the ones that prevailed and
they ceded to us this intrinsic urge to
invest experience with meaning and so
what do we do we make up I mean the
universe has no meaning it's just
collections of particles moving under
the laws of physics that's all that
there is you have this line where you
say we want you we want to hug the
universe and it's unrequited that's
right we urge for the universe to give
us something more than laws of physics
and being collections of particles but
the universe is unable to meet that need
so what do we do we make up our own
meaning and how do we make that up by
telling a whole variety of stories some
of them communicate information to our
peers and to the Next Generation but
some of it we tell in order to feel a
greater connection a greater social
connection to those around us a greater
connection to the Universe At Large and
those stories take a whole variety of
forms and I do consider the laws of
physics should be one very particular
very precise story that shows how we are
in a literal sense connected to the
cosmos but as you go up into the
Endeavors of human capacity to write
novels and plays and and to create it
evidences this urge for meaning and it
shows how wonderfully capable we are of
inventing
tools and techniques for giving us a
sense of Greater connection
and you you quote proust and who said
only through ART can we enter the secret
Universe of another
and I think that reflects also to the
question that you're asking about
language yeah yeah so language is only
one way of telling stories it's a
powerful way of telling stories because
it allows for a certain precision and
flexibility in the ideas that we want to
communicate but I think we're all deeply
aware that the ways of knowing the world
that are Beyond language not everybody
agrees with that right dickenstein would
not have agreed with that right the
limits of language are the limits of my
world is the approach that he envisioned
to be the case that it's all rooted in
language but I think anyone who's had
the experience which I don't want to get
all lofty here but if you have that sort
of transcendent moment which is not
something you articulate in words and
it's not an inner story that you're
telling yourself in words you just
experiencing this thing that's
transporting you to someplace else it's
a way of knowing the world that is
beyond language and I believe that's
what pruce was referring to yes it is it
I am I am I have spent my life getting
literal chills when I when I see a
Broadway show right and I'm I'm never
not grateful for it I'm like this is and
I don't have to have words for it this
this is what art does to me it may I
don't know what gives you chills but
well there are many examples and and to
me it's not only that I don't have words
yeah I'm thankful that I don't have
words because I don't want it to be
words when I try to put it into words I
diminish it it's just the raw experience
which itself is what matters
Transcendence yes so this there's a
question here and it leads into a story
I want you to tell so so you've just
expressed how
um the Arts are a way we deal with The
Human Condition and of course religion
and spirituality and belief there's
there's a chapter you have called brains
and belief and and you write The
evolutionary package deal the Victorious
evolved brain has qualities that Embrace
religion with open arms and someone here
asks in your view how does spirituality
fit into the Practical understanding we
have of ourselves and our place in the
universe would you please tell the story
of
um walking with your dad and your sister
in the late 60s at the um what's it
called The nomberg Band Shell that's
just right on poet's walk in Central
Park yeah so you you know this was the
late 60s although my my brother corrects
me it was probably 1970. uh so it'll be
in the the next next Edition uh but um
you know so uh my brother's 13 years
older than I am and he left to be a Hare
Krishna in in the 60s and I had not seen
him in in quite some a long time and so
my father took my sister and I to what
was a Hare Krishna happening at the at
the Bandshell there and uh I'm looking
and I'm like oh my God is that my
brother you know shaved head and playing
and singing and it was quite a moment
for me because I had no idea at that
point that he had gone into this this
particular face and so it was my
father's way of I don't know gently
taking us to this realization that his
life had gone in a different direction
than perhaps we had anticipated
and you you write about how his
his your brothers they
search for stability you you have you
have a healthy respect for religion in
this book that that why people need it
right or spirituality in your words and
you write about your brothers his Vedic
search for stability is akin to the lure
you found studying fundamental physics
yeah again
um I I really do see
spiritual and religious practice as one
of the other stories that we tell and
again
that's in no way
meant to diminish
any of these particular
undertakings and perspectives and
beliefs but rather I do see as I said
physics is a story science is a story
and so as we human beings search for
meaning and purpose there are many ways
that we do that and for some imagining
that there is something beyond the
physical is the way that they're able to
get to a place of comfort and my view is
look we are these little creatures
crawling around
this non-descript planet that's orbiting
this completely ordinary star in the
suburbs of a completely ordinary Galaxy
which is one of hundreds of billions of
galaxies Each of which has hundreds of
billions of stars and now with the James
Webb Space Telescope we're learning that
basically all of those stars have
planets so we're talking about hundreds
of billions of hundreds of billions of
planets out there right and in this
immensity of space who wouldn't be
anxious
right who who wouldn't have some need
for something beyond the everyday to try
to give us a sense of stability and
connection yeah I in my life have done
that through through physics and through
trying to understand the Deep physical
structure of things and connecting it to
things of the everyday but many others
Go in different directions and I respect
anything that gives someone that Comfort
again look religion has been used in
many ways not all good by any means we
can go down down the trajectory but
everybody knows what I'm referring to so
if your belief system gives you comfort
and allows you to live in this utterly
absurd reality that we're thrust into
that's a fantastic thing and should be
respected
there's no way to absorb this book
without
constantly referring to one's own
entropic existence right the the macro
can always be boiled down to the micro
as as we read this and my experience now
having read this twice is that this book
rips with poignancy this is a this is so
this book is so poignant to me and I
wonder of all your books was this the
most emotional because you share very
very
beautiful
personal stories
yeah no no absolutely I mean um
I mean string theory is emotional so I
uh you know elegant no but uh but you're
ABS absolutely there's no comparison I
mean every other book that I wrote was
ultimately about trying to explain
some deep part of science right that's
really what it was all about thank you
and this book was not so much about
explaining the science as to explaining
how it is that we human beings how do we
fit into this Grand cosmological Story
and and how do we make sense of it and
how do we cope with it and and what will
be in the far future and yes there was
certainly for me dark moments when I was
writing this book as I came to terms
with things that I've been thinking
about for decades ultimately I came out
of the experience with a very positive
perspective I didn't you know look
there's a when we talk about the far
future and and we learn that stars
disintegrate and plan is disintegrating
galaxies that should integrate and black
holes disintegrate into a spray of
particles that will walk through the
darkness that far future can feel Bleak
right and and and it's so Bleak and you
can imagine that you know on your
darkest day however Bleak and
insignificant you might feel thinking
about this kind of far future
you know makes it even more Bleak and
insignificant right I mean that's
certainly one way that you can come out
of this but my view is quite the reverse
my view is
you know I mean Nabokov said that we
humans are a brief crack of Light
Between Two eternities Of Darkness now
he was really talking about the
individual there's a period before
you're born a period after you die and
as you live that's that brief crack of
light right but it's true of the cosmos
more generally right humanity and life
and Consciousness is a brief crack of
light we're like a sliver between two
eternities of Darkness
and so you know my view is that's true
but how
fortunate and spectacular it is that we
get to participate in that how unlikely
is it that particles happen to coalesce
into a structure called faith and a
structure called Brian the odds against
it are immense and yet we are here and
so the view is
if you recognize how improbable it is
that we are here and on top of that you
recognize how amazing is it that a
collection of particles can think and
feel and love and hate and imagine and
create and you know build the pyramids
and construct the Great Wall approve the
Pythagorean theorem build rocket ships
go to the Moon look back to a fraction
of a second after the beginning
wow right that we can do that yeah and
so when you focus on that brief crack of
light as the place where you invest
meaning you can come out I think in a
very positive outlook
it I have I have to share my own um
recent um it's called nomberg Bandshell
right yeah you all know where it is
right right the poet's walk and it it
makes me think of someone fully
celebrating his Humanity just a couple
days ago I was walking by after dropping
my daughter off at school I walked
through Central Park it's seven it's
like 8 15 in the morning some dude is in
the Bandshell all by himself singing The
Impossible Dream at the top of his lungs
and he started like 52 Keys too high so
so and it's New York so everybody's just
walking by except and then there are
people doing Tai Chi over there but I
stop and I film it and when he gets to
this note that he cannot reach it's that
line
um to reach the impo The Impossible star
and he stops and he goes
yeah
yeah I was like that's New York and and
that is a man who was he was looking at
his finite existence in the face and
he's like I'm gonna reach that
unreachable star
um God You Gotta Love New York
um this is this is I mean this is part
of this tags on to your to you to what
you just said someone wants to know how
do you deal with your imper impermanence
and and that leads to another question I
wanted to ask you which is
what do you want your legacy to be well
I I I don't think it's about Legacy I
think there was a time I think when I
bought in to that
cultural perspective that it's all about
leaving something a trace for the future
but when you realize that cosmologically
speaking
it every Trace evaporates is that really
what we should focus upon and and so
again it's it's really a focus more on
on the everyday look this is not a new
idea that we should focus on the here
and the now but for me getting to it
through this cosmological journey
emphasizes it in a way that previously
never had a pull on me the way that it
does in this setup so it really is not
about trying to leave a legacy it's
about trying to live fully to trying to
actualize and and and and and and family
and relationship in the Here and Now is
where the footprint is
before
um before we close I wanted to share
something which is that as I said I read
this book first three years ago and then
when I knew I was going to talk to you
again I picked it up and and I'm I'm
flipping through and I found
on on page 163 I had apparently three
years ago just stuck in this Post-it
that my daughter who was then five and
is now about to be nine wrote and it
just says thank you I love you so much
and just seeing how her handwriting has
changed like now this is you know she
scrawled this out and she got it right
now she does cursive and she writes
Mandarin characters and but she still
says that to me and and you look the
same as you did three years ago
obviously I look the same as I did three
years ago but but our kids right our our
kids are the ones that grow so fast that
remind us how time has changed and if
and if there's anything
that can stop time even for a nanosecond
it's what you said it's it's this it's
this memory of how
precious our lives are and how
miraculous it is that we're here yeah
without a doubt you you write I just
want to close with your own words
um
you write uh is in the last chapter we
are ephemeral we are evanescent yet Our
Moment is rare and extraordinary a
recognition that allows us to make
life's impermanence and the scarcity of
self-reflective awareness the basis for
value and a foundation of gratitude and
this moment is rare and you are
extraordinary and I'm we are also
grateful for your work and your
generosity of spirit thank you thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you